let's start from the beginning yeah you
you got arrested what happened so
the the overlay here is the january 6th
so-called select committee
which um is selected basically of a
bunch of democrats and two rhino
republicans it's a committee which nancy
call pelosi yourself called
unprecedented because it's a totally
partisan committee which i repeatedly
called long before i ever got a subpoena
a witch hunt in a kangaroo court
designed to build a criminal case
against trump which you can't do okay
you know they put me in that stuff right
yeah they showed a clip of me reading a
news article oh interesting and then
claimed that i was a trump supporter
calling for people to go never never did
they lied jamie raskin is a liar and an
awful person yes
anyway i uh so they they um
subpoena me
uh and command me that's the term they
use to come and testify
before congress and provide them with
some documents now here's the
constitutional problem and the rocket
and hard place i'm in as soon as they
did that
we have the fact that trump
invokes what's called executive
privilege okay executive privilege it
goes back to george washington it's a
doctrine
it it it might you know the word
privilege has kind of got a bad rep
these days but the whole idea is for a
president to make effective decisions he
has to be able to have confidential
discussions with his closest advisors
that can't be revealed in the ordinary
course of business so as soon as he
evoked in privilege number one it was
not my privilege to wave number two so i
told the committee repeatedly time and
time again
go negotiate a waiver of the privilege
with the president and his attorneys
this is the same argument that steve
bannon's legal team uh used right that
he that trump had invoked executive
privilege and he was not same argument
did mark meadows the former chief of
staff
they're arguing you lose the president
loses executive privilege the moment he
walks out of office which is a fanciful
and absurd notion which has no basis in
the law
the point here would mean that you have
no privilege during the presidency
either it's ridiculous it's privileged
it's crazy the office not to the
individual it's great well
uh be careful with that because that's
kind of their argument in some sense the
the the just go back to the logic of
this it makes no sense if president
trump understands
trump has executive privilege and and
his predecessor comes in and immediately
strips him over and then he never had it
yeah but i don't think you should be
able to strip the presidency of its
privilege it's just that's okay well so
so it's not the office it's the
individual who held who held the office
like any president who goes in and says
i this privilege is required for the
the reason of having independent
branches if you left and then that could
be taken away from you you'd have civil
war every every four years literally
less less tangent can a can a new
president uh get the information from
the old president's privilege or are
they privileged from each other like
they're not allowed to know what each
other has done when a when a a president
past or present invokes executive
privilege then that privilege applies to
what whatever it is he's invoked it on
and it's not
the
authority of his advisors who are
considered the top advisors we're
considered alter egos of the president
in other words when they subpoena me
it's like subpoenaing the president so
my point here in terms of my situation
is
trump invokes privilege not my privilege
to wave the committee does nothing to
resolve that issue and the next thing we
know
they
pass a resolution
to hold both vance gavino and myself in
condemn for for failing to comply with
the subpoena
and
okay hi jinx ensue now the the funny
part of the story and it's the darkly
comic uh in a brutal
uh authoritarian way is i live literally
a field goal kick away from the fbi i
mean i i was a field goal kicker in high
school i could hit the fbi
with a from my
from my balcony in the building i'm in
with a field goal that's how close they
are yet what's what's a good field goal
though how many yards are we talking
like 40 40 yards 40 yeah yeah i mean
it's just it's just right there right
and so
um
rather than
it
what they should have done with me
is
call my attorney and arrange what they
call a voluntary arrest this is a
misdemeanor right just hey we've gotta
arrest him for it come on down we'll do
the paperwork and you know you'll be out
out with it with no bail and you know
we'll we'll deal with this in the courts
that's how it should have went and two
days before they took me i actually
talked to the fbi agent
and said hey whatever you need i'm happy
to cooperate with you guys and that same
day i'd sent a letter to the
uh the attorney uh the you know at the
justice department saying hey i'm
looking for a modus vivendi here call
call this attorney here i'm stuck
between this rock and hard place so it's
like peace right peace
peace brother right peace you know why
and so
on on that friday uh they they let me
leave my home across the street from
them
go to reagan airport sit for an hour in
the boarding area getting ready to go
board a plane to nashville to do mike
huckabee show
and i go through i do my gate ticket
thing and walk into the jet way and the
next thing i know there's three armed
agents behind me and two armed agents
coming at me right
and
it's like
they take my phone can't call an
attorney put me in handcuffs
take me down the jet way and meanwhile
as soon as that's happening it was like
all the newspapers
had been leaked you know all the media
had this leaked but they kept me in
solitary right and i go i get
fingerprinted i go and get leg irons
strip searched
and you know the
one of the common things is like they're
walking me down and this this guy young
guy i got no problem with with the
people who work at the place you're just
doing their job unlike the fbi which
seems to enjoy doing that job too much
um yeah this guy's walking i'm supposed
to be following and i'm in leg irons you
ever tried to walk in like cards it's
it's not easy right and then they'd walk
me down to the cell they take away my
tie because they think i'm going to hang
myself and my belt because they think
i'm going to hang myself
and um
it's
it's just like
why'd they put you in leg irons
so we can't escape
you know i think they wanted these well
it's bullying coercion look tim look
well i mean you're you're a master
sprinter yeah you rival you're saying
this field goal kicker in high school
but this guy man is pure athleticism but
they wanted the optics is really what it
is they wanted to show you they want to
bully coerce me and and and try to break
me and and look it's like people are
crooked it's like there's a thing a
concept called law fair that we've been
having to deal with in the trump
administration really big time
it's like even if if i'm never convicted
and put in prison for two years which is
what they want to do it's going to cost
me
well over a million dollars just to
defend myself and i'm a misdemeanor over
a misdemeanor and i'm not you know i'm
not i'm not uh i'm not one of the wall
street guys who was in the trump
administration just you know as a
college professor before i got here it's
like what the hell it's like what's
going on here guys um so you get the
bigger issue though and i get back look
the taking back trump's america book
it's a mission for me it's also my legal
defense one but we got to get the house
back we got to get the house back in
november i don't think it's bullying i
don't i don't think it's what do you
think it is i think they want they want
to send a message
to anybody who would work with trump if
trump wins
we will put you in no i i that's i agree
with that it's like
who look who wants to go into government
service i mean all i ever did was all i
ever did was save lives and create jobs
there nobody ever accused me of doing
anything but that the response
from anyone who would want to work with
trump after seeing what they did to you
should be to proudly assert they want to
work with trump and try 10 times harder
to work with trump in the next
administration make them realize when
they do things like this
people will only become more resolved
and stand up for what they believe in
this is why
the united states doesn't negotiate with
terrorists
i this is this is what i learned doing
all the hostile environment stuff
training with with the overseas
um
like when you're dealing with
terrorists terrorists don't like in many
circumstances to kidnap americans
because amer the united states
government will not negotiate at all
they'll just send special forces or
whatever to go and wipe them out and
rescue the americans or the americans
die and so what ends up happening is
typically
at least this is what you know how it
was a while ago things changed with isis
you could have an american gets
kidnapped in the middle east they go
he's an american leave i don't want to
deal with it but a german guy or a
spanish guy those countries they pay up
instantly so what happens they're more
likely to be kidnapped
so what you need the message you need to
send when they do things like this they
want to scare you
make yourself
stand up
be ten times more resolved and say okay
if you want to play these games we're
gonna we're gonna try twice as hard 10
times as hard to stand up for what we
believe in work with trump and take back
america
couldn't agree with you more
there's also just a very practical
matter of taking back the house of
representatives and getting the
investigatory powers in the hands of
republicans who will then
send out the subpoenas
to the fbi to the justice department to
the national archives to the democrats
on capitol hill to the white house
uh i just
tim
it's
this this all stinks to high heaven i
mean this is like this is like banana
republic stuff where whoever is in power
tries to punish and imprison
whoever was in power before so that they
can't come back i mean it's a it's a
it's a story that's been going on
for for hundreds of years in countries
around the world we just never thought
it could happen here why do you think
it's happening here i mean at one point
you were a democrat right do you think
that the party has fundamentally become
flawed or what evolution has taken place
well if you look at the democrat party
itself
the the democrat party that i associated
with
was blue collar america it was it was
the maga folks who want
real wages and decent jobs rising and
it's and
we just the democrat party lost their
way long long long ago i mean
i just want to pause real quick and be
like you know they were the party of
slavery and jim crow and the clan and
all that well there is that too yeah
they've had a lot of problems for a long
time look i think probably all of us
sitting around this table are more more
pragmatic pragmatists
um rather than partisans uh you know i i
wanted when i registered as a republican
i wanted to register as a trump
republican because i know what that
means yeah one of the cool things in the
trump taking back trump's america book
is to is to walk through what i call the
iron triangle of mega right it's like
the rhinos
love tax cuts they love deregulation hey
trump trump republicans are on board
with that fine
fine
strategic energy dominance that too okay
what differentiates
the trump republicans
it's an end endless wars
it's secure borders and at the top of
that triangle or pyramid it's it's fair
trade and a level playing field so blue
collar manufacturing workers can compete
against the sweatshops of asia and the
subsidies of europe uh and and and
that's what
really
trump republicism
means to me and we you know we we had
look
it's what is it uh bill parcells nfl you
are what your record says your record in
the trump administration strip all the
rhetoric away says that we built the
strongest economy in modern history okay
we have turned the strongest economy in
modern history over to a regime
which and you folks are way too young to
understand this
um is a replay of the worst decade of
the 20th century which is the 1970s in
many ways the 70s
were
they certainly rivaled the great
depression years because just for the
sheer length of time they went on i mean
you can't imagine what it's like to have
mortgage rates at 15
i mean that's like you say you're out of
your mind navarro no you go back in the
70s
and we the misery index of reagan was
you know double yeah 10 and unemployment
rate 10 interest rates and you were in
the reagan white house right
no no it never was in i you know i
interestingly enough um
and forgive me if i mention this but i i
i explain
that back uh back in the 80s when i was
getting my phd at harvard i did have a
chance to do that um there was a guy
murray wiedenbaum
who uh was the chairman of economic
advice advisors
and he invited me uh to be his uh his
speech writer essentially because i i
did like op-eds back then like in the
wall street journal and it caught his
eye
but i decided
that
if i ever left
harvard i'd never get come back and
finish so i think i probably made the
right choice though thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and we'll see you all
there
you